hi I'm Jess and you're watching game
[ __ ] news is top 5 episode later in the
show you'll see I'm presenting with my
friends Dan and Ed so look forward to
that you can hit that subscribe button
if you're on YouTube to see if I'm able
to come up with a better in turn next
time so now here's some big story last
week Nintendo announced that the legend
of zelda breath of the wild was getting
a twenty dollar deal safe us and a bunch
you guys went no because there's one
thing games don't like it's paying extra
money for a thing that already cost them
a bunch of money Nintendo have waited
Nintendo's built r in and told IGN that
it's in Nintendo's nature to use every
last minute of dev time to make the game
as good as it can be and given they made
the massive worlds of Hyrule they
considered it a waste to just to make
one game and have that be the end of it
the result of that was the DLC path
which is coming out in two packs this
summer and this holiday season
respectively the first includes a new
cave of trials challenge and hard road
and the second has a new story in
dungeon turn and explain that the
content is in development now which is
why it's not coming out for a while and
ruminated that fans would have responded
better if Nintendo had been able to
share more about the DLC packs he said
he expects the elder fans will be happy
to know that more zelda is coming later
this year breath of the wild arrives on
March third force which and were you so
we all know that overwatch is the only
game that matters anymore and we all
know that there's a new character coming
soon but who is it gonna be and what
kind of crazy [ __ ] are they gonna do
well was it have spent a week dropping
hints for the Internet to froth over
first up overwatch director Jeff Kaplan
said hero 24 is not who you think it is
meaning that doom fist a character who's
been in the spotlight because of Terry
Crews wanting to voice him probably
isn't next then there was an official
blog post which published in in the
universe interview with 11 year old
scientist from new Bonnie feo dolly
assume that a sayin she's a gifted child
who has experience with robots and AI it
mentions she's received a research grant
she bought her own drones as a kid and
now she's going on a holiday and it's
our first time playing and then some
eagle-eyed folks at eSports site PvP
live would notice that the in-game
rivals board in the new Bonnie state had
changed in a variety of ways in our
recent update finally Jeff Kaplan
revealed a bit of very early concept art
as part of his opening keynote at the
dice summit in Vegas which fitted a
giant robot spider and a bunch of
smaller spiders around it he said no the
hero in the center is not the hero who
you think it is so speculation is rife
well the next hero be the giant spider
will it be eleven-year-old scientist Fe
will it be the eleven-year-old
scientists Fe controlling dine spiders I
would be all over that last one but will
probably be finding out more very soon
through the magic of cinema we've
changed sets because well the aircon was
way too loud where we were so we just
came into a free meeting room and now
it's really echo in here anyway the
Nintendo switches digital games appear
to adhere to the pulley principle as
they can't exist simultaneously on
multiple systems the Pauli exclusion
principle is the quantum mechanical
principle that states that two or more
identical fermions cannot occupy the
same quantum state within a quantum
system simultaneously in this
unnecessary comparison your digital copy
of breath of the wild is a fermion and
your switch is the quantum system got it
good youtuber crazy dope tastic captured
a recent Q&A session with Nintendo
Entertainment Planning and Development
general manager shinya takahashi when
asked by an audience member if they'd be
able to buy digital games from the eShop
once and have them playable on multiple
systems Takahashi answered currently we
don't have a system like that in place
than in 10 posts which he went on to say
but we haven't made any final decisions
about how we would approach that going
forward so unfortunately I can't provide
any concrete answer for you right now
well that's not the best news we
recently learned that all Nintendo eShop
purchases will soon be tied to your
Nintendo account which is at least a
small step in the right direction bit of
a PSA for you guys the Ghost Recon
wildlands open beta is happening right
now so you can go play it I mean totally
under the video it'll still be there in
two minutes the open beta is available
on ps4 xbox one and pc and will run
until februari 27 the beta includes
everything from the closed beta as well
as more content that takes place in a
province called monti rock where you'll
be taking on strongholds held by the
fearsome
de blanca cartel if you want a leg up
you can check out our video that gives
you five things worth knowing before
digging into the beta if you're an xbox
user I can't absolutely promise you'll
be able to play the crash bandicoot
remaster trilogy but you might be able
to which is definitely a step up from
won't be able to the upcoming Crash
Bandicoot insane trilogy which includes
the first three crash games has only
been announced for ps4 where it launches
on jun 30 but the story doesn't end
there the PlayStation Islands Twitter
account recently replied to a tweet that
has since been deleted saying the game
will be exclusive to ps4 the new tweet
clarifying the deleted tweet states it
will be coming to playstation 4 and ps4
pro first which heavily implies that the
trilogy is a timed exclusive Activision
of not concerned whether this is the
case just make on-site we show you how
to make a me on Nintendo switch review
horizon zero dawn and give you our
impression of Mass Effect Andromeda some
of it from us this week but be sure to
have yourselves a lovely weekend and the
US will be taken care of you next week
so I will see you after that